erst ein paar industrie einstellen
heute habe ich eine bezaubernde
assistentin dabei meint peter brown
hallo ihr lieben
oder ihr könnt sie ganz einfach selbst
aber wieso haben wir zweimal frankreich
cds eingespielt
bin ich froh dass jetzt aber genug zu
mir versprochen sie fressen darauf
schlag ich stehe total
hallo mein apartment möchte ich nochmal
nach
zeigst du uns wie das geht
wie heißt du nichts museums lupe
wie machen das waren die eindrücke von
den letzten zwei jahren die ich hier auf
youtube verbracht habe genau zwei jahre
ist es schon her aber ich muss euch
jetzt erst mal begrüßen hallo und
herzlich willkommen in meiner trockene
ich hab's nämlich in meinen etwa 108 und
videos einer nicht gesagt und hat sich
dort gleich und fisch deswegen herzlich
willkommen in line 8 ich möchte dieses
video machte zum einen dass ich mich
bedeuten kann bei 100.000 abonnenten
es ist wirklich eine unfassbare zahl für
mich ich weiß noch dass ich im letzten
jahr im august und gewinnt spiel gemacht
habe als 10.000 abonnenten erreicht hat
und heute ein jahr später machen zum
gewinn steht weil ich immer tausende
heißt habe ihr wisst ja ich bin so ein
kleines mädchen und lebt auf dem land so
halt und wir haben hier in den
ortsteilen oder zahl von 22.000 und wenn
ich mir überlege okay ist fünfmal so
viele die 1300 zuschauer finde ich das
wirklich unfassbar und ich mich einfach
bedanken für eure treue dass ihr immer
einschaltet dass er meine league ist
kommentiert mehr eure fotos steckt auf
instagram und facebook und wie schon
angekündigt werde es auch bald ein
twitter account haben und auch da
fleißig mit euch chatten und mit euch
twitter heiß glaube ich auf jeden fall
hatte ich dieses video schon mal gedreht
aber vor leider viel zu lang und sei
jetzt schon mal ein kleines video
hochgeladen habe nämlich meinen küchen
video das etwa 44 minuten ging habe ich
gedacht dieses video muss ich jetzt ganz
kurz halten
ich wollte eigentlich ein bisschen was
geschichtliches einbauen wie es zu
youtube kam und wie ich mich überhaupt
getraut habe sofort die kamera aber ich
mache es einfach mal irgendwann an
es interessiert ihr könnt den kommentar
da lassen und heute möchte ich euch
einfach noch ganz kurz erzählen wirklich
ruhe bevor es zum gewinnspiel geht was
jetzt in zukunft auf mich zukommt meine
zuschauer natürlich stark gewachsen ich
habe 100.000 abonnenten es geht darauf
viele die mich nicht abonniert haben und
dennoch jedes mal einschalten
ich hab im moment pro monat etwa zwei
millionen videoabrufe was sich eine
enorme zahl ist und ich bedanke mich
echt auch bei allen die mich nicht
abonniert haben sie trotzdem einschalten
aber ich find's ganz komisch abonniert
weil ich dann auch über euch erfahren
kann
denn ich kann die statistiken anschauen
und weil sie all ihr seid und woher er
kommt und dass ich mir so ein feedback
ich möchte einfach kurz erzählen ich
habe ja im letzten jahr meinen shop
eröffnet bei den online shop und stelle
oft auch wirklich zufall ihnen vertrauen
können ich hab damit produkte drin die
ich toll finde
und aus diesem grund werden wir auch
bald einen job bei uns in der nähe
eröffnet heute in dem großen globus
markt das kam einfach weil ich erwarte
schon an der aktion gemacht hat und sagt
einfach die idee auf sandy noch 300
schock in unserem laden und den möchte
ich dann nutzen zum einen damit sie eben
dort auch die produkte bekommen die ich
gut finde
zum anderen aber weil ich doch auch
bank- und kochkurse gegen will und das
ist auch so ein ganz großes
regen von euch dass ich auch mal bargeld
kurse gebe und dort jetzt eben dann am
wochenende jeweils backkurse und
kochkurse geben und die termine geben
wir euch noch bekannt das wird jetzt
alles in nächster zeit starten ganz
genauen termine kann ich euch nicht
sagen aber ich halte euch auf dem
laufenden
und wieso habt ihr euch jetzt erzählt
ich freue mich auch nochmal eure hilfe
oder ihre hilfe und zwar möchte ich
unter der woche weil ich halt leider
meine lehrerberuf bisschen aufgeben muss
weil es einfach zeitlich nicht reich und
weil's einfach mit den
einstellungschancen im moment sehr
schwierig ist in baden württemberg hat
sich das mit dem lehrerdasein nissan für
13 jahre wohnen und möchtest aber auch
unter der woche kochkurse für kinder
geben und diese sollen kostenlos
stattfinden weil ich einfach viel dass
wir möglichst viele kinder kommen können
und mit mir gemeinsam sich über
ernährung austauschen mehr kochen und
backen und einfach so ein bisschen das
gesundheitsbewusstsein wiederkommt ich
möchte dass die kurse kostenlos
stattfinden und deswegen brauche ich
dann noch einen sponsor mich dabei
unterstützt dieses projekt zu
verwirklichen
ich brauche jemanden der zum beispiel
die kinder abholen kann an den schulen
und in den kindergärten ich möchte nicht
dass wir auch gruppen teilnehmen können
und eben auch was die lebensmittel zum
beispiel gestellt hatten und da macht
jetzt praktisch schon zur aufgrund von
suchen jemanden der helfen kann meine
nächsten projekte realisieren ich so
viel praktische unternehmen was mir
helfen
gleiche unternehmen das sich gern sozial
engagiert und einfach eine soziale
verantwortung hat und wenn jemand kennt
oder wenn sie mich gleich angesprochen
fühlen dann können sie ihn beschreiben
unter info als tennissocken welt.de
ich hab da einfach auf mein team jetzt
hinter mir was sich darum kümmert und
auch dieses freue ich mich schon richtig
das ist so mein nächstes projekt
und jetzt möchte ich gar nicht weiter
über meine projekte sprechen ist sie auf
dem bahnhof kommen und so weiter und so
fort und meine eigene sendung aber
darüber informiere ich euch schon
einfach mal anders
ich möchte jetzt meinen gewinnspiel
kommen ich habe mir nämlich ganz tolle
preise ausgesucht wie ich es gerne
verlosen möchte einfach um euch ein
kleines dankeschön zurück zu geben und
ich stelle euch es einfach mal die
preise vor
insgesamt sind es sieben stück und ich
hoffe sie gefallen euch bevor ich euch
hat die gewinne zeigen möchte ich euch
sagen wir das teilnehmen könnt und zwar
könnt ihr mir einen kommentar hier bei
youtube hinterlassen aber auch einen
kommentar bei facebook und zwar wird es
so aussehen schreibt mir vielleicht
einfach in den kommentar seit wann ihr
mich anschaut oder seit wann nämlich
kennt wie er mich gefunden hat und dann
nehmt ihr schon automatisch teil ausser
wenn ihr in klammer dazu schreibt ich
möchte nicht teilnehmen aber trotzdem
das video kommentieren das gab es auch
schon
ich werde dann so machen dass ich das
automatisch dann auslosen lassen und
zwar gibt es dann vier gewinner vier
gewinner auf youtube und drei gewinner
auf facebook und ihr könnt bei facebook
so teilnehmen das ihr unter diesem video
post kommentiert ihr könnt aber auch
noch zusätzlich noch einmal in den
lostopf kommen wenn ihr mein video teilt
da müsst ihr nur darauf achten dass ihr
es öffentlichkeit und diesen beitrag
hier teilt sonst kann ich das ganze
nicht mehr nachvollziehen und das sind
praktisch so die mitmachregeln vor
die gewinner auslosen und werde dann
eben das video veröffentlichen das
dauert natürlich wahrscheinlich bis
freitags 22 uhr oder so und dann oder am
samstag und dann habt ihr ab dem
zeitpunkt 24
zeit um euch bei mir zu melden und zwar
die facebook gewinner über facebook und
die youtube gewinner dann bitte über
youtube damit ich einfach nachvollziehen
kann dass ihr das zeit und jetzt zeige
ich euch die gewinne
hey das sieht jetzt alles ziemlich viel
aus aber ich möchte mich bei euch
bedanken und deswegen bekommt ihr
einfach machen
der erste preis das ist so
das ist ein spezieller preis ist nämlich
ein protein freier preis und bei diesen
gewinnen möchte schreibt einfach bitte
egal ob bei facebook oder youtube hinter
seinem kommentar kloten frei dann weiß
ich dass sie dieses päckchen gewinnen
wollt ich hatte nämlich nochmal ein paar
dutzend freie produkte und da ich finde
dass er sie besser gebrauchen könnt gibt
es einmal dieses päckchen zu gewinnen
mit glutenfreien nudeln konflikts einem
brot backt mix & butter keksen dann gibt
es auf meinem türkei urlaub ein gewürz
päckchen und dieses fleisch zwei mal und
zwar und zwar nicht in der türkei ganz
viele gewürze gekauft und dachte mir ich
nehme jetzt dieses süße päckchen mit und
verlost es dann an euch dass auch ein
kleines angetrieben das ist das was ich
vor dem bösen beschützen soll
er glaube ich dran dann gibt es zwei mal
jeweils 25 euro gutschein
diese sind dann für meinen job gültig
für sammys - shop.de und diese werde ich
dann für euch signieren und euch dann
schicken
dann kommt der zweitgrößte preis unfall
ist es mein von don starterset da ist
enthalten eine packung von dort drei
lebensmittel verpassten eine
kristallkugel verfahren modelliert steht
becker sterkel der edding gehört mir
blumen zum ausstechen und ein von land
kletter und dieses set hat einen wert
von etwa 50 euro
und mein größter preis das ist mein back
starter set aus meinem shop
darin sind enthalten einmal
ein torten retter in egg ich einmal in
wunsch eine back folie hier noch trocken
ringe und eckig und und und mein
backblech und das sind die sachen die
ich gerne unter euch verlosen möchte und
ich drücke euch natürlich allen die
daumen und natürlich kann ich keine
hunderttausend preise verlosen aber ich
hoffe dass ihr euch darüber freut und
fleißig mit macht ich freue mich über
eure kommentare und bedanke mich
wirklich noch mal bei euch allen ich
freue mich immer über eure kommentare
über eure bewertungen und ich schneide
ich jetzt im nachhinein noch ein paar
sachen aus dem anderen video rein mit
ist zu lang geworden ist was sie aber
ganz schön lustig fand ich wünsche euch
eine noch einen ganz schönen tag und bis
zum nächsten mal tschüss verluste wissen
was diese diese schalen
die wollen wir doch nicht gibt das
nächste mal
ich muss nochmal schönere aus der türkei
holen dann gibt es nächstes mal nehme
ich diese schönen schälchen dich aus der
türkei mitgebracht habe dann zeigt wenn
ich nächstes mal wieder rast verlose und
mal in der türkei bin bringe ich euch
schildchen mit dem verlags die weil ihr
euch immer so gut gefallen
die nächste frage ist und die wird auch
ganz gut aufgestellt
wann zeigt sich dein mann endlich vor
der kamera also mein mann wirklich denkt
nie vor der kamera zeigen hier neulich
ganz kurz
nummer so bis zu hals eben gezeigt also
nix amira die leckeren kuchen verweilen
geburtstag gepackt nicht mehr da steht
die menge der kamera und redet uns da
immer ran und das war ich das recht
wirklich im fuß zu keiner sehen
vielleicht die die in meinem alter sind
oder ein bisschen älter oder vielleicht
ein bisschen jünger die kennen das
wahrscheinlich kann man werde hier macht
und der referentin nachbar wilson
den hat man immer öfter gesehen aber nur
die augen und hell von der nase mit
einem gut auf und manchmal später
mysteriös bleibt mysteriös
kinder müssen auf die schwester helga
kanal der mutter gestand der
euro-minister sport ganz oft werde ich
gefragt
sli was kannst du nicht kann ich euch
ganz einfach beantworten ich kann kochen
nicht verpacken ich kann malen und
zeichnen was kann es nicht ich kann
nicht singen und eine weitere schwäche
von mir ist geografie also nicht nur
dass sich die flaggen nicht bestimmen
kann ich hab's auch wirklich mal
geschafft in der schule damals im
französischunterricht des fells
großbritannien zu kennzeichnen mit
schweiz und hat man das wort schweiz auf
französisch übersetzt und habe keinen
punkt gekriegt aber ich fahre ich der
festen überzeugung dieses feld wertig
schweiz ausser leiter portal
und jetzt kommt der topf frage und ihr
werdet nicht glauben was für eine frage
ist wahrscheinlich verschafften sie auch
schon gestellt sondern sie beim letzten
video es sei oft gefragt und war laut
umfrage ist der schwache fragt meine
frau eigentlich nicht mehr ist es auch
schon mal passiert dass ich eine fraktur
kantons oder schwanger bist nicht
zugelassen und
nun zu meiner freunde wissen natürlich
nicht
als endlich mein gipsabdruck von samira
also entweder habe ich zu viel gegessen
und weisungen
manchmal passiert sehen das land auch
nicht klar
und ja ich bin nicht schwanger wir
wissen nicht wann und ihr werdet dann
zum schluss erfahren mindestens 3
ja ich freue mich aufs nächste mal und
lege mein bauch ist wieder ab denn
übrigens total gut gefällt da könntest
ganz wird schnitzel essen ohne dass es
jemandem auffällt und stets was kochen
ist dann